running wild and free for now at least
while elephants aren't on the verge of
extinction more countries could lose
their herds altogether destruction of
habitat conflict with people overland
and poaching threaten the elephant down
a backstreet in Hanoi the capital of
Vietnam the floor of a timber plant is
strewn with elephant ivory the result of
illegal poaching far from here but
traded in Vietnam where it's possible to
buy pretty much anything using your
phone one man told an undercover
investigator from a group campaigning
against the illegal wildlife trade how
he's able to open his container full of
ivory inside a customs compound standing
next to officials who are supposed to
stop him campaigners say more needs to
be done to tackle the traffickers in
Vietnam which has become the global hub
for the illegal trade we think there are
compelling reasons to use these
non-compliance proceedings against
Vietnam so we are calling on all
scientists parties and world governments
in Geneva this month to begin these
non-compliance proceedings on against
Vietnam with the view that if
significant progress is not demonstrated
urgently that they should be slapped
with trade suspensions Vietnam is under
pressure to reform its practices and
just bowed to do more there have been
modest increases in elephant populations
in Kenya Malawi and Uganda but losses in
Tanzania Mozambique and the Democratic
Republic of Congo conflict with people /
habitat loss is a problem but so too is
poaching that's despite the 1989
international ban on the trade in ivory
there are estimated to be about 400,000
elephants in sub-saharan Africa it's
also estimated 55 African elephants are
killed for their ivory every day that's
20,000 a year there is a long-standing
debate about whether ivory stocks should
be sold or whether that would provide a
further cover for the illegal trade
campaigners say wildlife crime is
worsening that more needs to be done
before it's too late
Emma Haywood al-jazeera